hello everyone this is sami here from
audio science review
uh we're back to basics today
on a concept and terminology that i'm
sure you've heard a ton about
and that's uh blind testing and control
testing and audio
um it was the video was prompted by
someone uh sending me this uh
video by uh
paul mcgowan from uh
ps audio
and uh where he talked about how he does
plenty of blind testing and that the
future of the company depends on him
getting it right
and unfortunately the process of
explaining how he does blind testing is
very clear that he doesn't understand
the reason and methodology and
proper methodology to perform such tests
prior to this we had also danny from gr
research talking about his cables and
how their
amazing cables and that he can pass
blind tests easily
and
that um
he would uh produce such a video for us
actually showing us his blind testing
which he unfortunately never done
uh even though it's been good few months
since he
made that promise
i'm not trying to complain about them
but i i do get rubbed the wrong way when
people in the industry
claim to a know
what they're talking about and
uh just have no knowledge of the topic
they're talking uh it's one thing for
individual audiophiles to not understand
the nature of these tests it's entirely
another when you have a company you have
resources you have money and
and as paul said uh you know your future
of your company may depend on it uh that
you want to understand these things and
and do it right
so let me tell you up front the punch
line is that nothing they're doing is
valid uh no results they're generating
is useful uh they're really wasting
their own time uh doing those tests but
uh let's get into it and i'm gonna cover
this sort of a to z
independent of just you know the
mistakes they've made
let me start at top level and really
this goes to the heart and the mission
of what we do on our audio science
review
which is to produce reliable results in
whatever we do whether i'm reviewing
equipment or i'm listening to something
what is the point of producing something
where i tell you x is you know equal to
w but it's not a reliable thing you need
to be able to demonstrate that what
you're saying is true
beyond just spitting out an opinion
and if there's also not reliable don't
say it
on this thing so
this is key thing anybody can do any
kind of test generate any kind of result
but if it's not reliable if it's not
dependable it's of no value it's
remarkable how many people get this
wrong online and reviews and in this
case industry people
so
let me step back and say there's a the
proper terminology in here is not a
blind test it's a control test
blindness is just one of the things one
of the tools we have to build the
control test
what is a control test in a control test
we're trying to
isolate everything
else that is uh interfering with the
results that we want in case of audio
our number one goal is is fidelity and
we may be comparing two products against
each other and the main thing is the
sound that comes out of these audio
devices right uh whether you know
whether they look different or price
different their design different all of
that is
secondary information
which unfortunately complete and bias
the listener and have them vote
improperly and incorrectly
if the only thing that matters are your
ears and what you're hearing
then we need to
create tests where that's all you that's
the only sensory input you're getting
because all other sensory input are
non-audible aspects of the test and we
don't want those interfering because the
moment they do
we're not talking about just the sound
anymore we're talking about a
combination of things that uh
that just you know not useful um and uh
i don't need to tell you that you know
this this is a standard protocol that's
used in in everything uh out there where
people want to get reliable results uh
on this thing medicine of course a prime
example but even taste tests uh
on this thing and you know food and
drinks and what have you
um as i alluded to a little earlier a
blindness is one aspect of developing
such a controlled test
and by blinding we take away the
identity of what you're listening to
and that is so so important because you
know no matter who you are you can be
influenced by um you know the shape size
brand or more importantly just literally
cheat you know if i tell you this is a
ten thousand dollar deck and this is a
twenty dollar deck and you know you're
inclined to say that ten thousand dollar
decks are better than 20 dollar ones if
you know which is which
you know all bets are off in this thing
so
we uh apply a blinding mechanism and
this doesn't mean literally blindfold
although that can be useful too um but
this is just one of the factors and this
is the most obvious factor everybody
knows about uh although it's tricky to
execute um but at least i think anybody
watching this video probably has heard
the term blinding and knows that it
you know refers to not knowing the
identity of of what you're testing
um
there are many ways we could do audio
tests uh the most uh common one is um
that we're interested in is uh you know
you got two devices one is a one is b
um which is which and uh i play sample
for you and i say you tell me if it's a
or b
and
uh you could guess a you could guess b
and that's called the fourth choice you
can't say w right there's only two
devices and you get to vote one or the
other uh i may ask you to rate a sound
quality from one to five let's say uh
you could say three you could say four
you could say one you could say five but
you can't say 50.
um in that case there are multiple
choice questions
in there and uh
you could get lucky by guessing right if
it's a or b and i present you with some
sample you could just get lucky
or you could think you know but you
really don't but your guess is correct
and we need to be able to tell
whether you truly are hearing something
versus
just a random guess
now in your mind again you may be
thinking you're 100 not guessing and so
forth but from our point of view the
rest of the world that wants to listen
to your conclusions of what you're
claiming to be that this this amplifier
sounds better than this other amplifier
if you want the rest of us to believe
we can't be in your mind right all we
can do is look at the results of your
testing and we need to be able to tell
how reliable that that test is
um if you go back to your days of being
in school and taking exams with multiple
choice
you guessed right when you didn't know
the answer and you were right
one of the things that also happens in
in audio tests is that when a person
doesn't know the answer usually they
don't give up they just sort of vote
randomly you just say oh look at that
say that's b that's c okay i can't tell
i'm just randomly gonna guess so we need
to find out about all this you know at
some point because again if we don't
find these aspects in somebody's testing
then we don't know how reliable the
results are and therefore we can't trust
it or and count on it
now what i'm going to explain to you
is
aim that
you individually whether you're paul or
you know danny or
you know any anybody who's watching this
you're applying audiophile and you want
to know the truth about audio what is
the truth about audio again it's only
the sound that you hear not everything
else that your brain knows about and and
can rely on and uh
for that
there are two ways we could do this you
could do it in a friendly testing and
the other one called hostile testing
hostile testing would be me going to
bowel's facility and say okay paul you
think you can tell the difference
between this amp and this other amp i'm
going to run a test and i'm going to put
in all these protocols and i'm going
gonna be on the lookout for you uh being
able to tell what i'm doing and and not
telling me how something sounds but
you're cheating and looking for tells as
it's called
this is not a presentation about that
that kind of protocol it turns out to be
very difficult to execute and you need
to have so many safeguards in there to
keep the person from cheating and again
reliable results this one's is if at all
i've enticed you to
to
do a proper objective test of you know
by listening of audio equipment and
learn for yourself whether they are
there aren't any differences so that's
the aim of the rest of this presentation
uh you know doing it for formal research
publishing papers and so forth that
requires far more than what i'm going to
talk about although the core principles
are the same
but in this case i'm just teaching you
what to do
in in
taking the test and generating reliable
results which you can by the way come
and then say on a forum or a youtube
comment say hey i've taken this test and
here are my results and have people say
aha okay those are something we can pay
attention to rather than
uh listen to this amp the other one one
has better sound stage than the other
one and this one has you know
harsher highs or whatever that kind of
thing we just dismiss out of hand
because again it's not a control test
so um
we need to make a test blind right
that's the first thing we talked about
and the key thing in here is not knowing
which is which
and if you can't do this then
don't bother right we've got to avoid if
you're testing two different things and
comparing them we've got to hide these
things um
one way to do it is to use an electronic
switcher of some sort and an a b
switcher and uh
and you don't know which one is a and
which one is b have somebody else come
connect the cables and let's say testing
cables and then you can flip a and b a
lot of people will say whoa you know i
don't want to have a switch in the path
in there that could have its own
distortion fine have somebody that you
in your household or friend or loved one
uh
you know switch these cables you can
turn your back and have them switch it
and then you know then you can listen to
the system and
uh um you know and
write down you know and you know listen
and then pass a judgment on it
the key here is to avoid any tells and
tells it's just you know something that
basically gives away gives that away uh
you're doing this testing for your own
good you're trying to learn something
don't fool yourself don't try to cheat
uh the temptation is high when you're
taking these tests and you get
frustrated he's ah maybe i could tell
one was a little louder or whatever
but the whole point of this thing is
you've got to not be able to tell the
identity of these things but again i'm
hoping that you know what blinding means
in general
the next one is familiar to many people
also
although executing it correctly is is
not easy um we've got to match levels
levels have this incredible effect where
you can literally enhance the fidelity
of one device versus the other even if
they're 100 identical by having one be
slightly louder what does the loudness
do loudness unless you hear lower uh
notes that decays into nothing if the
volume is low after you know yes it's a
piano another guitar picking goes
and goes into noise floor and disappears
at some point but if i have a higher
level then it takes it longer to decay
down and that's an it won't an example
of something that's very enjoyable uh
a you know bass that's impactful that's
louder and you know and kicks harder uh
if it's louder then it's it's gonna
sound good uh until it gets distorted
then it does a reverse but assuming it's
not getting distorted i can't tell you
how many times i have fallen prey to
this despite everything i know if i
don't get the levels 100 percent right
i'm listening to an ap test i'm like
gosh it sounds
you know better than the other one and
then i measure levels notice that that
was louder as soon as i compensate it's
like all sudden the door closes on you
and that difference vanishes
so remarkably and you turn up the volume
and all those characteristics that
you're reading subjective reviews come
to life everything sounds more alive
details get better
noise floor goes down because there's
more accentuation in the dynamic range
so
absolutely critical that you have to
match levels and unfortunately this is a
bit technical
on this thing and
i'll talk about it in a second but
you've got to do this if you can't do
this then don't do the test and this is
one of the things that paul did wrong in
his test
where he didn't talk about matching
levels at all fortunately
a lot of the blind tests you can do
without worrying about levels and that's
what i call the easy case in here where
uh oops
uh where
they uh
the advice themselves or what you're
testing doesn't either impact the uh um
the uh levels power cables or you know
tweaks or you know stands or footers or
there's a lot of things that basically
cannot and will not change levels now is
it good to also check levels any way it
is but
uh you know it's it's not always
necessary uh to match levels uh two
digital cables uh to uh
i was gonna say two streamers but
streamers can also resample audio and
things like that so it's a remote chance
levels may change but maybe you're lucky
and a lot of the fights we have in audio
is around things that are basically
impossible for them to make any change
and and they're really not changing
levels so even if you think you're
they're changing levels so i personally
would be okay if you have this class a
device and you don't say anything about
level matching um because the you know
if the levels are changing then game's
over they did make a difference on this
thing now if it's a two different
devices where
levels could be different to different
decks there's no standards in digital to
analog converters preamps in audio in
general we don't have many standards
that people stick to for levels it's
easily easy to find two dacs on one
outputs 4.4 volts the other one outputs
3.9 volts or even more extreme it's a
core dac that puts out 3.5 volts or
something like that that nobody uses but
if you compare it to a dac that puts out
two volts well clearly this is going to
sound a lot louder than the other one
now on these things there
also them
divides into two categories some of them
you can level match and i'll talk about
how you could do that but some of them
you cannot easily level match
i often do headphone amp tests and i get
a tube amp which has a high output
impedance
the problem with the two bamboo or any
amp device but high output impedance is
that if you hook them up to a headphone
that has variable frequency response
which is most headphones
the two interact it actually changes the
frequency response of the headphone
if it's going to do that then what how
do you adjust levels maybe it just
boosts the bass but not the highs
or maybe it mixes both of them some of
the frequencies go down some go up
there is no one thing that you can match
and i tell you in those cases it can be
next to impossible to match levels
so how common are those tests i don't
know but if you have a
high output impedance device be careful
on that
so let's talk about the
the middle category which is an easy way
to test things um
you have two dacs two preamps two power
amplifiers something that you know can
have variable outputs um somehow find a
way to run a test tone and
you can download test stones from the
web and or use programs like room eq
wizard and create tones in there a
fidelity of it is not critical
whatsoever so if you have a laptop or
tablet whatever you could just hook up a
analog output of out of it or headphone
out fit from dongle it really not
critical take that cable and hook it up
to uh to your system and
play the two devices and if they have
volume controls adjust their volume
controls till they match uh if they
don't have volume controls then it gets
a lot more complicated and i'm not going
to dig into that but you got to find a
way to adjust this now how do you
measure it you can buy a multimeter
and these multimeters are as cheap as
30 40 dollars for a half decent one and
make sure you use a low frequency i'll
pick 200 hertz here's nothing magical
about that but don't go much above that
many of these
multimeters especially cheap ones have
limited bandwidth so
um and it can be a little bit
unpredictable what they measure about
their bandwidth so pick a low-ish
frequency and and run it and and you
basically put it in ac range
and uh hook it up to the output of your
devices you know test one measure that
it doesn't matter what it is unless it's
an amplifier measures 6.2 volts okay
take it out and hook it up to the other
one and measure 6.2 volts uh make sure
you don't short things out amplifiers
should have protection circuit but
that's the one device you could damage
uh if if you don't know what you're
doing um with apple fires you could also
use acoustic matching where you can use
a microphone and and then you don't have
that issue but that gets more involved
on this thing um one word of advice
after you do this matching play some
music and do the a b test make sure to
sound similar to you
i've done this and then like i said in
the case of high impedance devices i go
play some music some of them sound like
the levels matched then i play others
and the levels not matched so
make sure subjectively which is the test
we're going to run with our ears make
sure they do sound similar in level uh
on this thing if they're not then that's
no good
things get a little bit more complicated
um
if you want to do these tests properly
and a proper one the science says you
want to have a fast ability to switch
from one to the other
and and i'll talk about the improper way
for you in a second but the proper way
is how do you have two simultaneous
things playing uh if you're testing two
preamps or two power amplifiers or
whatever those are analog devices and
you can get splitter cables and split
the signal uh but when all these things
if you run into problems just post on a
forum whether it's audio science review
any other people will help you with
these things
um testing a digital device is more
complicated um let's say we want to test
two tags um there's a great tool on
windows i use which is my roon ron
media player roon that i use and it has
this multi-zone capability where you
could have as many dash as you want and
you can group them together and then you
can play the same content to all of them
and
that works very well for testing two
decks so i can take two decks gang them
up together and then anything i play
it gets gets fed to both of them and i
can then have an a b switch on the
output of the dax
and listen to them and if the dags have
volume controls or adjust their volumes
and if they don't in software and roon i
can adjust their volume room lets you
have independent volume controls there
too
and
makes a very difficult job doable
now there are people who don't believe
in this fast a b switching and they
think they should
spend hours and days and weeks and
months listening to one sample then
listen to the other one no problem
there's no requirement in control
testing that anything be done fast um
i don't recommend that you spend days do
listen to one than the other
it'll take you a long time to finish
this task but surely if the difference
is available to you night and day as
people always say oh i listen to one
daca's grainy i listen to this cable so
much better background and everything
well is that obvious then you don't need
days to listen to it right you know but
you're welcome to do a daily listening
test uh you know listen to one of them
for a day and then listen to the other
one for another day in that case you're
just switching gear
and just get a friend to uh or loved one
to come and and do the switching for you
so it's blind so you don't know today on
monday you have
uh dac a or cable a playing and the next
day could be a again or it could be b
and uh you basically you know once a day
you listen to one or the other
but do that science has conclusively
proven that when you do that you're
really screwing yourself there's no way
you're gonna remember what the sound was
like uh you know five minutes ago
literally
versus you know one day or five years
but
control testing and blindness and
doesn't dictate this a lot of people say
well blind testing says i gotta do it
quickly it doesn't you take all the time
in the world and the results will be
just as valid from point of view of
running a control test
this is the reason i actually made this
presentation this slide up to here a lot
of you knew of
what i was going to talk about but this
is the part that i find that most people
don't understand and if you don't do
this unfortunately the results are no
good at all you could match levels you
do everything else i said if you don't
do this you're is wrong
remember i talked about how we need to
tease out whether you're guessing or
where you're confused whether you
couldn't really tell
because the you know the answer is
always multiple choice on these things
it the answer to that is statistical
analysis and to have statistical
analysis of anything we need to have
more than one sample
if i flip a coin and i predict that it's
going to be head
and his head does that mean that i can
predict the outcome of any coin flip
the answer is no that was a lucky guess
right
let's repeat that five times
i flip the coin five times what if i get
all five times right
does that mean that i can predict that
answer is actually no
for that to be correct you need to get a
little over eight out of ten times right
before we have 95 percent confidence
that
the outcome is reliable
so if you're comparing two cables
comparing two directs two amps or two of
anything the classic a b test
then you want to run the test minimum of
10 times the more you do the
better the statistics are but for my
sake
if you ran it 10 times and you got 9 of
them right
good enough for an online internet
argument to go and say like i tested
these two things
and nine out of ten times
my guess was correct of which one i was
listening to
you get that that's caused enough for us
to stand back and say whoa there may be
something here let's repeat the test
let's see if we get the same thing but
if you come out and say hey i can walk
into a room listen to these two things
instantly i can tell which one's a which
one's b
that means zero means nothing if you did
it twice it means nothing if it means
three times and this is danny richards
mistake in this video uh well i could
walk in and instantly tell which cables
which uh you know maybe you do maybe you
don't uh first of all we weren't even
there to know that she guessed they
think correctly um one of the things
about statistics is that you need to
keep a lock you need to keep track and
and that is the documentation that we
need so a lot of times somebody says i
pass a blind test and so all right can
you explain the protocol and
documentation they're like no i just did
it blind and i could tell like no
show us a log like this that says hey
first time i got it right second time i
got right third time i didn't fourth
time i did fifth time i did sixth time i
did
and uh
then we can see we can see a log and
gives us some confidence to us that that
you got it right so this sounds like a
very high number but personally i like
to get 99 or 100 right actually i don't
even want to leave five percent to
chance so i'll often take a test where i
get 24 out of 25 times uh correct and
then i know and then what is the one
time wrong because you know sometimes
you're voting a and b you forget or you
get distracted when the differences get
small it's very hard and i've shown you
previous examples of that where if you
take an automated pro test like fubar's
abx test it will actually generate the
statistics for you and you'll
immediately see
that getting four out of five right
doesn't do you any good and by the way
where does this come come out this is
just basically you can guess a or b so
you have 50 chance of being right
probability is 0.5 you get it twice two
times in a row right is point five times
point five
and you gotta keep multiply by point
five till the the probability of being
uh guessing drops below 0.05
which is five and this is called p
greater than five uh p less than uh five
percent or 0.05 is what we want
um if the test is is for preference test
uh
where you're rating the fidelity of
speaker
then
then it's not a simple game like this
you got to understand what you're doing
and the best thing you can do is just
post the results to audio sounds reviews
somebody recently did this and i and
others that understand how to do the
statistical uh anova analysis that it's
called and we run it and then we can
actually tease out
you know even though everybody's just
raiding all these speakers against the
music they listen to you can actually
tease out the probability of chance
very easily out of those things so
there's good tools to do that but i'm
not going to get into how you do that
you need to really have a you know good
background in statistics to understand
now
go and get any paper
from
audio engineering society in case of
audio but also any medical research any
others and you'll see that the testing
part is really like half the paper or
one third of the paper the other two
thirds is full of statistical analysis
in this case
what i'm showing you is is uh research
uh from chanal of dr sean olive on
preference tests in here and it's just a
random paper that i took and you can see
all the statistical analysis that's
going on in here
and and not just one test they'll run
many many statistic tests to find that
for example maybe people prefer the
speaker
with certain tracks of music
or with all the music
or listener types male versus female old
versus young and so forth so you can
really dice and divide the results and
and get a lot of insight out of the test
on this thing so when somebody tells me
that
they just walked in did one or two tests
tells me that they've never ever seen a
single piece of research paper and audio
listening test
to have thought that one or two
iterations was good enough to say that
they are they can i can pass a blind
test
and how embarrassing is that that you're
an industry that you're building
products as you talk about fidelity that
you talk about blind testing that you
haven't even seen or read one paper
because you can't escape this
every paper that has a blind test in it
has multiple iterations in statistical
analysis every one of them without
exception from simpler paper to the
journal papers their peer review that go
on for uh 50 pages
they all do so when a person says i know
it all i'm sorry you know nothing about
this you've got to go back to basics
audio engineering society cost two or
three hundred dollars a year to join the
papers cost i think used to cost seven
bucks maybe some of them are a little
bit more now but if you're running a
company you can't afford to spend two or
three hundred dollars a year to get an
aes subscription and
download a few papers just go in there
and search for blind test control tests
and tons will pop out and you'll see
this stuff and if you don't understand
the statistics well done either go learn
it or stop claiming that you're running
blind tests
on this thing
so
i've talked about this earlier um if you
want to do this test then you want to do
it eight or ten times my suggestion is
uh you know if it's something you do in
longer term is to keep keep two logs
whoever doing this switching uh have
them keep it logged and make sure that
sometimes they switch sometimes they
don't there's random number generators
on the online that you can use and
create a sequence of a b and it could be
a a a b b b a b a whatever it should be
randomized if it's not randomized you're
actually violating some of the
principles and statistics that let's
just do the math and figure out the
probabilities in there so you should
randomize that and so they keep a log
and let's say you're doing the test for
10 days in a row or
or 10 times in a row they have their
cheat sheet and you take a cheat
log and you write down your answers
and at the end you compare the two and
see how many you got right
and uh if you didn't get
a nine out of ten right
let's say you know you just learned
something uh important about audio that
you didn't know
now this gets confused also danny
riccione's video says double-blind tests
of speaker cables are impossible because
the person doing the cable switching
will know what you're switching
therefore it's impossible to run a
double blind test and
the people say you should run double
flying tests are stupid
well first of all let's talk about where
did this double-blind test and the need
for that come from
um google clever hans and you'll land in
a wikipedia page with a very interesting
story about this horse
in germany whose name was clever hans
and the clever hans could do math not
just simple math you could do very
complicated solve logic problems uh you
could ask them you know what date was i
don't know tuesday
in march or something and the
the horse would pound this hoof
you know a count and he would stop at
that so it was ninth day of march she
would pound the hoof nine times and
after nine times would stop and
this was so magical and they took the
horse everywhere and uh
and would the owner would show all these
tricks you know multiply three by two
and
they would of course would do it six
times and uh it was quite a puzzle to uh
uh men of science
yeah on how this was possible so a
psychologist um
studied this and uh
ran a bunch of control tests and
realized that the only time that the
horse could tell
could give the right answers was when
his trainer was owner was there
if you took away the owner and asked the
questions the horse couldn't get any of
the right answers
and he realized what was happening was
that the horse was watching the owner
and the owner was making involuntary
gestures
when the right answer was given by the
horse so the horse will say the answer
is four and the horse would do one two
three four that says give the right
answer
involuntarily the owner would change its
uh you know what he was doing and a
horse was able to read that and he would
stop
uh the uh you know pounding those hoof
and
uh that was enough to uh uh for it to
get all the right answers so
uh
this is gets us to this what's called
clever hunts effect and this is
basically why single blind tests are no
good because if you are conducting a
test
you could have this communication
in this case it wasn't a verbal
communication with a person or in this
case an animal taking a test and you
convey the answer to them so let's say
i'm having you test that game versus
that b and uh i have that k i'm playing
and i say
now let's listen to that b
raising my eyebrows and if i you know
always do that then you you sort of
you know i praise the question wrong but
essentially if i always do you know
something like this i roll my you know
my arm some certain way
and even if i'm not doing it on purpose
um i could convey the answer to you
which is which and we don't want to do
that
so the solution to this is double blind
which means in this case instead of the
owner and trainer uh
asking you know being there you have a
you know
have him be behind the horse and the
horse can't see it
and uh
now performing double-blind tests it
gets very difficult like danny said how
you having somebody switch cables that
you know where they don't know what
cables are switching you know you can't
blindfold them and have them switch
cables you actually probably could if
you made it easy enough uh you could
make an electronic a b switch that's
automatically switching under computer
control so that becomes you know uh
random
or in my case i actually don't care if
you go to that rigorous standard
remember this is for your own learning
this isn't to publish something
so as far as i'm concerned if you have a
loved one coming and switch a to b and
then they walk out of the room and then
you turn and listen to your system
that's fine that they knew as long as
they didn't communicate anything to you
so that's the key thing making sure
whoever's doing this switching for you
whether you know if it's a computer is
done for you if it's a person just make
sure they don't communicate anything to
you and if we have to literally double
blind uh put a blinders on you we could
also do that then you can't see it's key
that there are no sounds you know
someone's plugging a cable and sounds
different than the other again don't try
to fool yourself these are for friendly
tests if it's a hostile test we have to
do a lot more um so i'm happy with
single blind test with the intent that
is doing what a double blind test would
do
it's not an excuse to not do any testing
because you can't do double blind and
understand that this is the nuance
between single and double blind don't
call everything double blind i have
people say i do double blind tests all
the time and when they explain it
it's clear they've done a single blind
test so it's not a double blind test um
a simple thing i do is that when i'm
testing equalization for example i you
know close my eyes and i have my you
know mouse on on the uh
on off button and i just hit it many
many times till i lose track of which
one is which then i just switch a and b
a and b and i b with my eyes closed and
then i open my eyes and see it so
that's not a proper double blind test
but it's good enough for the purposes
that we have in here
um just quick some faqs before we finish
uh people said blind tests are stressful
uh they they are if you've said
you know run water runs uphill and i'm
not testing you
you can't prove that yeah it can be very
stressful but these tasks are for you to
run uh you're doing in your home if you
can't tell at the end you are confused
you don't have to tell a single person
it's for your own sake and so therefore
it doesn't have to be stressful i do a
ton of these blind tests myself because
i want to know before i go write
something and embarrass myself i'll run
the test and there's nothing stressful
about it yes it's a it's something you
got to do take some effort but people
put that effort in anyway when they buy
comparing two pieces of audio gear
they're already doing it
so might as well just add some rigor and
some control to it
on this thing so
it's not stressful if it's not public if
it's public yes it's very stressful but
i have passed them you know i've been
challenged can you tell mp3 against wave
and
i said fine i'll take a piece of music
and you know do the a b test and i'll
find the difference and i'll show it to
them and then sometimes i can't and i'm
honest i'm like okay gave me four clips
on two of them i couldn't tell you know
but this other one i could and uh so
you know there's goodness and then you
learn a lot about audio by the way by
doing these a b test uh you actually get
become a better listener because you're
not focusing to pass a control test
where you know the results coming back
at you what the right answers are
the second criticism is that you know i
can't do them too fast uh you know i
want to you know it takes me a while to
listen and you know and something and as
i've said before take all the time you
want the world know that you're screwing
yourself every test in the world has
been done the moment you let people get
acclimated to stuff differences shrink
and even when we talk about speakers and
things the longer you wait uh the worse
your detection becomes but if you want
to do that go ahead you know we give you
two weeks to come back prove to us that
the you know two cables sound different
um
and the last one is the retort that we
get all the time my ears tell the truth
so i don't need to run any blind tests
for you and the answer is
great don't come and bother telling us
about it then if you if
what you believe is good enough for you
that's fine we don't care what you tell
yourself we care what you want to come
and tell us how much you want to push
down our throat by saying you better
believe me that this this cable sounds
better than the other one this tag is
better that one okay now you're making
it our business and you got to make it
our business we want reliable
information we want to know just what
the sound was we don't want to know the
whole picture of what influenced your
decision we just want to know the sound
on this thing so getting to the end get
used to talking about and asking people
we want control tests when somebody
comes in just tells you oh i could tell
this you know this is better than the
other one it doesn't sound plausible say
okay can you give us a control test and
what is a control test a control test
that has reliable results something we
can counter
and if you can't give that to us then
please don't waste our time i get this
fe2 three days somebody comes in as our
forum says you're all wrong i got this
ethernet switch that sounds twice as
good as this other ethernet switch
it's like you know come on
don't waste our time you know go tell
that somebody else you know those of us
who want reliable information we want
some proof point of what you're saying
is important we love you listening to
the results of your ears your hearing's
important to us but you gotta follow the
protocols in here
now that blind test is just a component
just saying the test is blind doesn't
make it good doesn't make it useful
it's just one aspect you got to tell us
everything else so the moment you come
in you say i've got scientific results
for you scientific result means walking
through all this
you match levels this way you control
the setup this way
you
you know test with blind single blind
how you control all that where's the
documentation then where's the
statistical results all of that you need
to present to us if something's not
plausible before anybody cares
on the side of the fence where we want
to have valid results on the side where
people want to believe in fantasies
uh yeah don't even bother with any of
this stuff you go by your you know
whatever uh ethernet switch and changes
power supply tell the world it sounds
even better now
more power to it just don't bother
telling the rest of us who go by logic
and and what we've been taught in all
sciences on this thing you need to
control volume
you need to have repetition on this
thing and
above all don't do this to go win
challenges do it to learn yourself about
your system and your knowledge of audio
there's so many myths you may be
believing in
and when you run this test all sudden
the air clears and
you know it literally is going to change
your audio file life to do to do this um
so i hope you know those of you who
watching this video are not a believer
in this some small percentage of you are
are inclined to now to go do it and you
now at least know that the things you
got to get right maybe you don't know
all the specifics and again come on the
forum and ask
membership is happy to guide you with
all the details of what you're trying to
do or
warn you that's a very difficult test to
draw on but
you know whatever you do you need to
participate and do a few of these tests
to really really understand audio
if you've never done blind tests at all
in your life
chances are you just haven't completed
that journey yet
okay i hope you found this
video useful i know some of it was
repetitious for those of you who've been
schooled in these things but even for
you i hope there was something new in
there
okay thanks for watching and see you in
a future video bye-bye